circadian rhythms underpin almost every
aspect of our health and well-being and
that was the bit I wanted to get across
within Lifetime and that we in a sense
avoid these rhythms at our Peril for
biology to function it requires the
right materials in the right
concentration delivered to the right
tissues and organs at the right time of
day and it's the Circadian system that
delivers this extraordinary temporal
structure what are the consequences of
ignoring this biology as we do for night
shift work 24 7 society and it's not all
doom and gloom by understanding this
biology we can very much enhance our
health and our well-being
hey friends and welcome back to Deep
dive the weekly podcast where every week
I have the immense privilege of sitting
down with academics and entrepreneurs
and authors and creators and other
inspiring people and we find out how
they got to where they are and the
strategies and tools we can learn from
them to help us live our best lives now
this episode is very exciting it is an
interview with Professor Russell Foster
who is the professor of circadian
neuroscience and head of the Department
of Ophthalmology at the University of
Oxford he has recently published this
new book lifetime the new science of the
body clock and how it can revolutionize
your sleep and health and so in this
episode I asked Professor Foster all
about the Circadian rhythm the body
clock and all the different practical
actionable strategies that we can use
that take advantage of our circadian
rhythms and our body clock to help level
up our health in terms of our eating and
our exercise and our nutrition and our
sleep crucially so I hope you enjoy this
conversation what is the difference
between your book Lifetime and why we
sleep fundamentally I approach the the
the the project really from a circadian
basis so a 24-hour biology so
essentially everything is being adjusted
to a to to a lesser or greater extent by
this internal body clock asication
rhythms sleep is part of it and so I've
taken a much more sort of global look at
our 24 uh our biology and made Sleep
part of that but not the main focus okay
yeah because the subtitle the new the
new signs of the body clock and how it
can revolutionize your sleep and health
yes I guess so it's it's kind of weird
so like I mean I went through six years
Medical School two years working as a
doctor we did so little on circadian
rhythms Beyond like a second year and
neuro lecture on the eyes where eyes are
so complicated anyway it's just like oh
my God photoreceptors and this all of
all of the things that circadian rhythm
wasn't was very much an afterthought
sleep was very much an afterthought
nutrition was very much an afterthought
there was only really when I read why we
sleep that I started to be like oh the
circadian rhythms are in fact a thing
and then listening to a few Cuban lab
episodes about it around kind of getting
light in the morning versus not in the
evening oh wait a minute caffeine a dead
and you know adenosine and all these
things which kind of words that I picked
up from medical school but didn't quite
apply to the context of how we can
actually improve our lives so I guess
like what is what's going on with with
the body clock broadly where do we where
do we start the discussion well I I
think the the remarkable thing for me is
that we've spent 20 25 30 years trying
to understand how these endogenous
24-hour oscillations are generated when
I started
um and I and I moved from the UK to to
the States this was the focus how does
the clock tick and
some of the great people you know the
Nobel Prize in 2017 uh you know Ross
bash uh Hall uh and young we would come
to University of Virginia because we're
all part of the same National Science
Foundation Center for biological timing
give talks and they used to get it wrong
a lot
um but as the data accumulated and the
and the facts changed they corrected the
story and so what we had by the Nobel
Prize was a pretty complete
understanding how you can generate a
biological clock which is completely
awesome you know essentially you've got
a bunch of clock genes which are turned
on they produce a bunch of proteins they
form a complex they go into the nucleus
they turn those genes off
um the proteins are then broken down and
then they're released from this
inhibition and can start producing more
proteins again so you have this 24-hour
oscillation in protein production and
then degradation and that's the the
essence of the clock and and certainly I
was in involved in Earl experiments
showing that the master clock in the
brain is a group of 50 000 cells called
the suprachiasmatic nuclei and we
thought that would drive rhythmicity uh
and it would impose a 25 24-hour order
on the body we got that wrong in a sense
every cell in the body has this internal
clock and so what you've got is a master
clock in the brain then coordinating the
rhythmic activity of billions of
individual cellular oscillators
throughout the organ systems of the body
fine-tuning our biology to anticipate
the very demands of activity and rest in
the day night cycle and so with that
Exquisite mechanistic understanding and
the knowledge for example that a single
amino acid change in one of those clock
genes can either make you a morning
person or an evening person is so good
it's the best
system that we have of understanding how
genes and their protein products
interact to generate behavior and it's
still the best example we have so but in
parallel with that Exquisite mechanistic
understanding which is really my
background because I'm interested in how
light interacts with the master clock
and regulates it was the appreciation
that
circadian rhythms underpin almost every
aspect of our health and well-being and
and that was the bit I wanted to get
across uh within within Lifetime and
that we in a sense avoid
um or ignore these rhythms that are
apparel uh because if you think about it
for biology to function it it requires
the right materials in the right
concentration delivered to the right
tissues and organs at the right time of
day and it's the Circadian system that
actually delivers this extraordinary
temporal structure and so
um what are the consequences of of of of
ignoring this biology as we do for night
shift work 24 7 society and you know
that that wonderful arrogance of Being
Human I mean part of our extraordinary
um achievement has been that we believe
that we're independent of the
constraints of of The Grubby world of
biology and we're not you know and it
was really I think it was a bit of a
wake-up call to think hang on
um you need to think about this and it's
not all doom and gloom by understanding
this biology we can very much enhance
our our health and our well-being love
it so okay so I have so many like
specific questions but I wonder if we so
if we start more
further Upstream so you've got super
casual cosmetic nucleus where there's 50
000 cells or so that are sort of the
Master Clock your body and they're
somehow helping regulate the other
billions of cells that we have in the
body which also have some level of like
circadian rhythmicity to them yes what
let's say it's night time for a cell
versus daytime for a cell
in like I don't know the the finger like
what difference does it actually make
the clock's a a sort of made in broadly
the same way it we don't think there's
any fundamental difference in the Master
Clock compared to a finger clock for
example uh but they're phasing the
alignment of those clocks can be very
different and it's and it's essentially
how they take their reference cue from
from the master clock that's important
now what you've got is a a master clock
and it's no use to anticipate these
daily changes unless it's set to the
real world and so our interest has been
well how does the Master Clock use the
dusk Dawn cycle the light dark cycle to
regulate internal time and that's really
how I got into this sort of mechanistic
side of things and the appreciation that
in fact it's not the visual cells the
rods and cones that are providing this
light dark signal it's in fact a third
photoreceptor in the eye and so the eye
we can think of it I mean it's you know
obviously the eyes so cool in lots of
different reasons but it's both the
organ of of space through vision but
it's also the organ of time because of
its regulation of the internal Master
Clock in the brain and if you don't have
eyes you are both
um space blind but also timelined and in
fact we're working with blind veterans
UK
those individuals who have radical eye
damage or have they've lost their eyes
they're they're drifting through a world
without time these are extraordinary
individuals
um very very keen to be independent and
some of the some of the discussions I've
had you know one chat was telling me I
feel so angry because I feel my body is
trying to trick me all the time and went
on to tell me about a story whereby he
knew that Wednesdays is when he he cut
the grass and so he woke up I think knew
it was a Wednesday because that was the
next day I went downstairs and had
worked out a way to cut the grass being
completely blind and then uh his wife
came down and said it's 3am in the
morning and you're going to drive the
neighbors crazy and and it was that
incredible sense of frustration it's
essentially it's a bit like unremitting
jet lag for the rest of your life and so
the most recent work that we're doing is
you know we could discover these new
photoreceptors and that's so kind of
cool you've got this this dual function
of the eye but but it's really working
out how they interact with a molecular
Clockwork
and we're now at a stage where We've Got
Drugs which can mimic the effects of
light on the clock and the research I'm
doing now is to try and develop those
drugs so that we can give them to
individuals with radical eye disease no
eyes and give them back a sense of
biological time it's not just actually
the profoundly blind
um we've done quite a bit of work in the
space of uh psychiatric illness so the
Sleep weight patterns of individuals
with schizophrenia are are utterly
smashed I mean I to an extent I would
never have believed until we've done the
studies and so I also see a role for
those drugs in uh correcting as an acute
corrector of the circadian sleep wake
cycle and then hopefully not to use
drugs and then then use light but as an
immediate corrector
um in the context of Alzheimer's and
Dementia the reason my kids will send me
off to a nursing home will be because
I'll be wandering around in the middle
middle of the night terrifying
grandchildren if they ever producing it
but you know seriously if if we could um
delay the point at which one has to sort
of send an aged relative to the nursing
home because of their massively
disrupted sleep wake this would be
incredibly beneficial uh beneficial
beneficial you know for the healthcare
sector and but also the the emotional
trauma that families go through uh when
they have to make this very painful
decision so so by understanding the
nature of biological time I think
there's some really exciting
opportunities
yeah that's really cool um so
how does the how do the photoreceptor
cell respond cells respond to Dawn and
Dusk to regulate it's such a cool
question because yeah because they are I
mean I got into this because I couldn't
understand how the visual cells the rods
and cones which grab light in a fraction
of a second milliseconds then they
forget they've seen that light and
that's how we get an image of the world
um and if they if they took longer then
our visual world will be a blur as we
moved our head it would be a series it
would be a smear not a series of sharp
images and I couldn't see how the rods
and cones could extract dawn dusk
information over long periods of time
and what we did know before we started
is that they're really quite insensitive
to light so you needed a lot of light
for a long period of time and I guess
having a background in sensory ecology
whereby sensory cells are are fine-tuned
to their you know the demands the
sensory demand I couldn't understand how
a visual cell could also act as a
circadian cell so we started working
with mice with hereditary retinal
disorders whereby their visual cells had
largely degenerated they were visually
blind but what was so extraordinary is
that when we looked at their ability to
regulate their circadian rhythms to a
light dark cycle and essentially what
you do is you put them in a running
wheel like a hamster running wheel and
look when they run and when they don't
run and you get a beautiful read out of
their circadian Behavior they could do
it perfectly well when you covered the
eyes then this ability had gone so there
had to be something else in the eye now
when we proposed that
as I talk about in in the book I mean I
remember there was a big big meeting in
the states where I said so these data
are consistent with the fact that there
could well be another receptor system in
the eye this person at the back of the
auditorium stood up and I thought okay
well they're going to ask a question
fair enough and I sort of looked at at
them and they looked at me and they just
said [ __ ] and walked out and you
know it got really nasty I mean grants
were hit the deck one comment from a
referee was is Foster cersling telling
us that after 150 years of research on
the eye we'd missed an entire light
detecting system and so you know I was a
bit younger then full of full of um I
suppose yeah arrogance yeah
um so do yes these These are the data
but it took us a decade to to get better
and better data ultimately engineering a
mouse with absolutely no rods and cones
so you couldn't use the argument oh well
it's just a few rods and cones left that
are mediating this light response
and what we discovered is this entirely
genetically engineered rodless countless
Mouse will regulate its responses to
light circadian responses light
perfectly normally and that led us to
find in a mouse a group of ganglion
cells that were directly light sensitive
the ganglion cells are the other cells
that form the optic nerve of the eye and
about one out of every hundred of those
is directly light sensitive David Burson
found the same thing in in the rat and
Denis Stacy found the same thing in
monkeys so you know after we we'd
slogged away for a decade
um then at about the same time we in the
mice you know other people in rats other
people who might show oh yeah
um there's something else and that I
think has been really incredibly
exciting because it's not just called
biology it has direct clinical
application and that's where the last
gasp of my scientific career was going
is is using that information uh
hopefully for health and well-being just
a quick message from one of our sponsors
and and we'll get right back to the
episode and this episode is very kindly
brought to you by Heights Heights is a
brain care smart supplement it is two
capsules that you take every day I've
been taking it for the last 12 months
and it contains over 20 evidence-based
micronutrients that you need to keep
your brain and body healthy like I said
I've been taking Heights every day for
the last 12 months and through that I've
actually become friends with the founder
Dan who we actually had on season one of
this podcast and this season we also
have an interview with neuroscientist
and psychiatrist Tara swart who is the
chief science officer at Heights as well
and one of the things I love about
Heights is the fact that every single
thing they do is very evidence-based
over on their blog on their website
they've got tons of Articles along with
links to all of the different papers
that they've cited that show all the
benefits of the various micronutrients
that they've got in these two little
capsules and the best thing about taking
these is that it's just two little
capsules every morning so you don't have
to deal with green sludge or any other
kind of faffrey it's just literally
taking two pills it's super easy to sign
up you just go on the website you put in
your address and they send you either
either a monthly or a quarterly
subscription I sign up to the quarterly
one myself because a it's cheaper and B
I'd have to take fewer deliveries and if
you use the coupon code Ali 15 at
checkout that will give you 15 off the
already discounted price of the
quarterly subscription so you can try
out Heights to your heart's content so
thank you so much Heights for sponsoring
this episode and for helping improve my
own brain care what was that like when
you first did that experiment covering
up the eyes of the mice and realizing
hang on they lose their circadian
activity was that like a Oh My God
moment or was it like oh there must be
something else going on here no it was
it was an oh my God moment because it
was consistent with the sort of the
theories but when you had unambiguous
data so the other thing is of course my
background is in comparative biology my
first group of zoology and I was I was
aware of weird photoreceptors so
non-mammalian virtual bits have pineal
photoreceptors they have even have
photoreceptors in the hypothalamus I
mean I know that sounds crazy with huge
amounts of light actually penetrate the
brain through the skull through the
skull and birds for example regulate
their seasonal biology that they can
detect the increasing and decreasing day
lengths with a receptor in the
hypothalamus in fact I worked on those
before I worked on mammals so the
conceptual leap that there could be a
weird receptor in the eye wasn't so huge
for me because I'd come from a
background of weird photoreceptors and I
think that's a really really interesting
perspective because so much of exciting
science is at the interface between
different disciplines yeah now you know
the chat that said we've been studying
the eye for 150 years was absolutely
dead right but they've been studying
Vision they hadn't been looking for
another role for the eye and so you find
what you're looking for yeah and so
someone with your background where
you've been studying these in an
entirely different context you put sort
of two and two together almost yeah and
it really in my undergraduate project
was recording from the sort of the
parietal eye electrophysiologically from
tadpoles and it's so cool because you
know Sean Elijah on this tiny little
structure and it changes its electrical
activity and it probably regulates
swimming Behavior did that with my my
third year project supervisor Alan
Roberts you know and and so uh it was I
think that that breadth of exposure to
different areas of science is so
important and sadly because there's so
much to learn these days we don't really
have time for the comparative bit Yeah I
suppose to get advanced in any one
specific field you have to devote your
life to that rather than kind of
dabbling with other fields or side
hustles almost Okay so we've got the
ganglion cell in the optic nerve which
is responding to light is it responding
to amount of light or wavelength like
what is it responding to and what's
happening then this is what what
actually the field is struggling with at
the moment because of course what
Architects and the lighting industry
want is what they call human-centric
lighting okay and what we which is
basically lighting that optimizes human
human function physiology Behavior so
what the lighting industry has really
focused upon is Aesthetics does it feel
nice and is it bright enough for color
vision for example so that's been
largely
um now of course what they want to do is
enhance the the light environment for
the regulation of the clock
um in the industrial setting and also
the domestic setting but the problem is
we haven't got all the parameters in
humans humans are profoundly insensitive
to light and we might want to ask one
yeah I mean compared to a Mouse a mouse
a mouse's circadian system can detect
light of one Lux which is you know
little more than Moonlight
um we get up to a hundred thousand Lux
on a bright sunny day so so that's
incredibly incentive and in fact it
wasn't until 1987 when scientists from
Japan show that in fact humans can
regulate their circadian system by light
it was always assumed and when I was
doing my PhD you know when asked that
question how do we relate our and
regulate our clocks it was always oh
well it's when we eat and it's our
social interaction and the problem is
everybody had been using stimuli that
worked brilliantly for mice but it was
just not enough and and what what the
Hondas did was something like 5 000 Lux
for I think it was six or eight hours
then they got entrainment
yes the regulation of the of the of the
internal clock to the external world
and wavelength I mean we showed that
these new photoreceptors are maximally
sensitive in the blue part of the
spectrum to be specific 480 nanometers
which is the kind of blue you get on a
really blue uh blue sky on a beautiful
sunny day
um why well it could be because at
Twilight the Dome of the sky is enriched
with blue light across the Horizon you
know you see it as orange but if you
look up it's that beautiful blue and
it's that wavelength where these
receptors are most sensitive and of
course it's at dawn and dusk when these
receptors need to be able to detect the
light and so we think but it's a just
those story that they're Mac that that
they're sort of sensitive in the blue
part of the spectrum
for maximum sensitivity at that time of
day however
although we showed there's a separate
photoreceptor and we originally
conceived it as visual rods and cones
non-visual photosensitive retinal
ganglion cells actually of course as you
might predict with Biology it's more
complicated than that in fact we now
know that the rods and cones are capable
of regulating the photosensitive retinal
ganglion cells okay so in fact the
spectral range can be quite large you
know because the cones go down in humans
to what 420 nanometers in the sort of
violet area and they go out to 560 which
is sort of green orange so how they
communicate with the photosensitive
retinal ganglion cells is unclear under
what circumstances whether they add to
the sensitivity and there's some
evidence from the monkey literature that
they might actually inhibit the
photosensitive retinal ganglion cells so
from it's a complicated light
environment that they're responding to
and in fact we and others have argued
that it might be if color vision might
have evolved to add additional
information because of course at
Twilight you get a change in the color
of the light environment and if you've
got two if you've got receptors tuned to
different colors they can detect they
can ratio those changes and then pass
that information on so it might be the
photosensitive retinal ganglion cells
are just doing brightness but they're
getting additional time information from
the visual cells relating to the changes
in the in in the color of the
environment now we don't know
um but that but there's there's all
those really fascinating ambitious the
sensitivity issue I think is really why
are we so why are we so insensitive to
light and I I'm guessing but but it
could well be that humans of course have
been playing with fire for maybe a
million years and of course farlight is
quite bright and and it could give a
a confusing light dark signal there
might have been rapid selection against
sensitivity so that these receptors were
not overly responding to a bonfire at
night exactly yeah uh so so it's tuned
to the sorts of light you get in the
environment at dawn and Dusk and so what
sort of proteins are being up or down
regulated once like with with the
Circadian yeah cycle so the the key
um targets for light activation are two
proteins called per one and per two what
do pro one and Pro 2 do well they're
part of that they're really critical in
the feedback but by turning them up or
in fact you can inhibit them as well
will mean that you'll advance or delay
that uh oscillation so you can use them
in in nature to align that that clock to
the external one I should have said that
of course the molecular Clockwork isn't
exactly 24 hours so for most of us the
body clock is a little bit under
constant conditions is a little bit
longer than 24 hours so if you or I went
to a deep dark cave constant light
constant temperature and people of
course have done that then we will get
up a little bit later and later and
later each day and so what happens is
that the daily light exposure nudges the
clock into alignment by up regulating
particularly per one and per two in that
in that feedback loop
and so once presumably quite a lot
Downstream of that you would have
I don't know the in the morning the body
would decide to be more alert and in the
evening would decide to be more sleepy
like is is that ultimately what's going
on yeah I mean essentially what what the
the clock is doing is providing a
temporal reference cue for all
Downstream physiology and behavior to to
to align itself so in anticipation of
waking up the uh blood pressure is
rising rapidly uh the cortisol levels
are rising rapidly
um and alertness is is being turned on
and of course at the other end of the
day those those physiological behavioral
parameters are sort of declining or
going into a different state I think
it's important to say that they're not
being turned off they're just going into
a different state because sleep is not a
shutting down of biology as we've sort
of you may well have been taught
um even as recently as when you did your
medical degree
um but in fact it's going to a different
state which is a uh as in fact some
areas of the brain are more active
during sleep than they are during wake
and so what's happening whilst we sleep
is that
um information that we've acquired
during the day is then laid to memory uh
and uh in those those that new
information is then integrated and so if
you want to come up with novel solutions
to complex problems a night of sleep has
been shown to hugely enhance our
capability of doing that so the brain is
is sort of not only just sort of storing
facts it's actually playing with
information and coming up with new ideas
which is why sleep is so important
because it's that incredible capacity
that humans have of problem solving and
it's sleep that that really helps us to
do that
same time uh you know the brain is
regulating the clearance of a whole
bench range of toxins from the from the
body
um and realigning our metabolic pathways
so that the stuff that's been burnt up
during the day is then rebuilt at night
so we can do it so it's it's it's these
wonderful different states of of sleep
and wake that are being underpinned uh
by the clock and of course it's
immensely complicated so you have to
have that timing uh uh you know across
the day and in space so the right organs
are doing the right things just a quick
message from one of our sponsors and
we'll get right back to the episode and
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by short form short form is the
world's best service that summarizes
books but it's way more than just book
summaries they almost have a whole study
guide for every book that they've got on
the platform where they've got a
one-page summary and then they also have
chapter by chapter breakdowns and it's
not just chapter by chapter breakdowns
also in between the chapter breakdowns
they have interactive exercise is where
you can engage more readily with the
ideas in the book short form covers
non-fiction books from a bunch of
different genres that you might be
interested in for example they've got a
load of stuff in the business world so
if for example you're an entrepreneur or
you want to become an entrepreneur
that'll be great for you they've got
books in motivation they've got books in
education they've got books and
lifestyle and communication basically
any genre of like non-fiction personal
development is self-helpy stuff that
will help you level up your life it's
all there on short form short form
Publishers new book guides and articles
every week and if you're a subscriber
then you get to vote on what book they
cover next and in fact through that
system I have voted for various books
for example I've recently Revisited the
short form guide to Atomic Habits by
James Claire I've read the book once I
think when it first came out when he was
interviewed in mattybella's podcast and
I thought the book was amazing but to be
honest like with most non-fiction books
once you've got the key ideas from it
re-reading the book especially sort of
like in fairly close proximity to your
rereadings doesn't necessarily help as
much as I love James clear but the short
form guide to Atomic habits is great for
revisiting the key ideas anyway if any
of that sounds up your street and you
would like to sign up to the world's
best service that summarizes books then
head over to shortform.com forward slash
Deep dive and that will give you a
completely free five-day trial and you
can try out the service to your heart's
content that link will also be in the
video description and in the show notes
and thank you so much short form for
sponsoring this episode
so I feel like we've got a good uh well
a basic kind of grounding in the
importance of the Circadian rhythm in
regulating important aspects of I guess
physiology and psychology
can we talk about
sleep now so I mean I read while we
sleep and I've listened to bunch of
podcast episodes about this but I just
love to get your take on a few of these
like frequently asked questions about
sleep so
um I guess the first one that comes to
mind is
six hours seven hours eight hours nine
hours what what's going on there
um I think the key thing for me is that
uh one shoe size doesn't fit all right
and uh one of the sort of slight
frustrations that's emerged is that an
average value is taken as the optimum
value for all of us and of course it
isn't uh across adults for example
healthy sleep can range from six hours
maybe slightly less than that
um out to 10 or 11 hours and so yes
there is an average uh but actually
there's so much individual variation
it's it's it's really I think wrong to
impose a specific amount for each of us
and the point of the book to some extent
is to allow people to Define what's
optimal for them how do I do that how do
you do that so yeah so how do you know
if you're not getting enough sleep well
it's you know it's the kind of things
our grandparents probably would have
told us they've asked that question
which is that
um do you need a partner or an alarm
clock to wake you up in the morning does
it take you a long time to wake up do
you crave caffeinated and sugar-rich
drinks during the day to keep you awake
have your friends family colleagues
reported that you're showing a lack of
empathy increased frustration they may
have noticed that you do stupid and
unreflective things
um and and when given the opportunities
to sleep let's say at the weekend and
very notably on holiday do you find your
sleep patterns change and and it's
really defining what each of us needs
and then trying to adopt behaviors that
defend that sleep pattern and and you
know we know for example that the
duration of sleep varies enormously
between individuals but not only that
their timing going back to the molecular
clock there are subtle changes which can
make you a morning person or an evening
person but also going going back to
light
that can contribute to what's called
your chronotype your morningness and
eveningness so morning light advances
the clock make you makes you get up
earlier evening light delays the clock
makes you get up later and go to bed
later evening light is in dusk light
so dusk delays morning advances the
clock so you're constantly being nudged
backwards and forwards and of course one
of the problems of our society is that
we don't get asymmetrical exposure to
light which can be a problem as in
you're not getting an equal amount of
advancing and delaying dawn dusk
exposure so we looked at a bunch of
University students around the world
um Australia New Zealand Germany Holland
and and in the UK and we show that those
were the latest chronotype those that
like to get up late and go to bed late
we're not getting warning light which
would have advanced the clock made them
get up earlier they were missing that
they were sleeping through the morning
but they were getting evening light
which would delay the clock which causes
them to sleep even though yeah so art
sleep timing is dependent upon our
genetics
and when we see light but also there's
another factor which is what how old we
are so from about the age of 10 there's
a tendency to want to go to bed later
and later and later peaks in lateness in
males about 21 21 and a half in females
about 19. so men tend to be later for
longer and then as we age we sort of
move to a more morning chronotype the
time we're in our late 50s early 60s
we're getting up and going to bed at
about the time we got up and went to bed
when we were 10. and that actually
changed almost perfectly correlates with
the changing levels of estrogen and
testosterone so that sharp rise during
puberty and then the sort of decline in
into old age so the point I'm making is
that not only is there lots of
differences between individuals in terms
of their their preference for how long
they want to sleep and when they want to
sleep but it changes as we age therefore
it's completely Daft to try and Define
the optimum sleep sleep you know at
stage the optimum sleep duration you
must get eight hours
um and and I I think it was kicking back
against that
which was one of the reasons for for
writing the book I mean people have
actually come up to me after public talk
and as before lockdown and one person
said to me I don't get eight hours of
sleep am I going to die and I said well
I can assure you you're going to die but
but it may have nothing to do with your
secretary and so people have become
um frightened about their sleep rather
than embracing the Sleep uh that they
get they become anxious about it there
was and it's reinforced by Sleep apps
it's worth bearing in mind that at the
moment No Sleep apps are are
um endorsed by any of the sleep
federations or FDA approved and of
course you know when you look at the
validation of many of these these apps
um you'll go into the paper and you'll
see it work perfectly for eight
undergraduates you know or uh in
California and that's about it but of
course the point I've just made is that
sleep changes as we um age and between
individuals and so one algorithm is also
not appropriate for telling us what good
sleep is people have come to me and said
oh do you believe in slow wave sleep and
I've sort of said yes kind of why and
they said well I don't think I'm getting
any because my app is telling me I don't
get any slow way of sleep and of course
these apps are
found the
um uh they just they can't detect that
they don't have the sensitivity to do
that and so people can get very badly
misled so so so there's a sort of the
mantras that are a bit frustrating you
must do this you must do that but it's
reinforced by sleep app saying we had a
good night's sleep or a bad night's
sleep and again we should be listening
to our own biology using very
straightforward
um uh sort of criteria that we've just
touched upon nice okay I have another
um potential myth that maybe you can
debunk which I wish I've heard a lot
which is that you might think you can
get by with six hours of sleep but when
you're 65 you're more likely to get
dementia and Alzheimer's and stuff so
make sure you get your eight hours it's
a good point I mean I would not want to
marginalize the importance of sleep
absolutely but I do think that we need
to take responsibility for it now if you
are in your middle years and you are you
know doing crazy sorts of things in
terms of business and all the rest of it
and and are chronically sleep deprived
then there is evidence that chronic
sleep deprivation in the middle years
will predispose your risk or increase
your risk to Alzheimer's and Dementia so
I think that's a serious issue but but
again it's horses for courses
um and I think most people know if
they're they're not getting the sleep
that they need yeah
um how important is it to wake up at the
same time every day I think it is
important because it reinforces all of
the sort of signals that regulate the
Circadian system so eating at the same
time uh getting light exposure at the
same time that all acts to stabilize
however having said that you know
there's going to be an occasion where
you have a party you're going to get up
late you know and sleep is is is very
Dynamic it's it's and I really can't
emphasize one size does not fit at all
yeah and and and because it's such a
dynamic and variable behavior um we can
you know it's it can be tweaked and it's
flexible
um yeah the other the other really
interesting myth that so many again
again people sort of perpetuate the myth
it's not only eight hours but it's eight
hours of uninterrupted sleep
and and of course what we know from uh
Roger Eckert's work uh from his
historical studies looking at sleep
patterns in the pre-industrial era is
that human sleep almost certainly wasn't
a single eight-hour block uh so so you
hear in the literature I had a wonderful
first sleep
um and uh you know I didn't have such a
great second sleep and there's Roger um
talks about a wonderful
um French uh Doctor Who says uh young
couples should make love after their
first sleep uh when they are less tired
and will be better at it I mean you know
so you've got this literature which is
sits out there and that then encouraged
people like Tom Weir to say okay well
let's find out what happens to modern
humans if we bring them into the lab
give them 12 hours of light 12 hours of
darkness and lo and behold you get
what's called biphasic uh a couple of
episodes of sleep separated by wake or
indeed polyphasic which is multiple
sleeps with interruptions throughout the
night if you look at all mammals again
that wonderful comparative perspective
all mammals show they don't show a
Consolidated bunch of snake it's it's
polyphasic or biphasic and indeed
societies today without electric light
show multiple wakings and seepings so
that bit of information is not out there
and so when people wake up in the middle
of the night think oh my God that's it
I'm never going to get back to sleep I'm
as I start drinking coffee and do my
emails which is nonsense if they stay
calm you don't necessarily have to stay
in bed you can keep the lights low do
something relaxing you will feel tired
again and then go back to sleep I know
people who you know listen to Radio 4
extra and you know we'll get through one
one person until we just the other day
they felt found that Melvin Bragg is
absolutely spectacular for getting them
off to sleep
um now that's I mean I love in our time
but but you know in the middle of the
night that that perhaps that voice is is
what's required to just gently get you
back to sleep and and again it's it's
finding out what works for you what you
find relaxing to get you back off to
sleep but but so many people are just
terrified of of waking in the middle of
the night in fact there's a there's a
condition recognized now called Sleep
anxiety
and where people are getting very
anxious about going to sleep because
they're frightened of how long it'll
take to get to sleep but also if they
wake up in the middle of the night all
right I feel like around the early 2010s
there was a bit of a movement of people
trying to figure out polyphasic sleep as
a productivity tool what's your take on
that it's in fact I'm I'm part of a
national sleep Foundation which is based
in the state's um consensus document on
this and you you have these um various
patterns whereby uh there's a total of
uh something like four or six hours of
sleep it may be two hours at night with
with various fragmented sleep during the
day and all of the data suggests that
this is a really bad idea and it's it's
sort of become very
um popular in the business sector you
know where people are saying oh yeah
I've you know I've just and actually
short term you're probably okay long
term uh it's really a bad idea and and
you know going back to the point we were
talking about earlier uh assessing one's
own sleep needs you've got to be pretty
careful about it because you can delude
yourself the problem is that the tired
brain can become so tired it can't
detect how tired it is and you know this
has been shown in taxi drivers you know
asked um do you you know you're okay
working for the night shift they say
yeah no problem fine you then look at
their cognitive abilities and they're
you know on the floor uh so you you
again need to be genuine in tuned with
what your individual sleep needs are and
the impact of sleep um disruption just a
quick note from one of our sponsors and
we'll get right back to the episode and
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by skillshare if you haven't heard
by now skillshare is probably the single
best place in the world to learn
anything online and the best thing about
skillshare sponsoring this podcast is
it's very exciting because I have
actually been a teacher on skillshare
since 2019 and I actually have 13
classes on skillshare yes 13. most of
the online courses I've ever made are on
skillshare where you can access them
completely for free by going to
skillshare.com forward slash deep dive
and you'll get a one month free trial
anyway on skill share there are
thousands of classes on all sorts of
topics from entrepreneurship and
business to Lifestyle design to Interior
Design to cooking to graphic design to
video editing like loads of stuff but in
particular you might like to check out
my own classes on productivity I have
three classes on skillshare all about
productivity we have the productivity
fundamentals we have productivity
creators and we have productivity
strategies and so if you want to do more
things with your time if you want to do
more of the things that matter to you in
a way that's fun and sustainable you
might like to check out those classes
which again you can check out completely
for free by just going to skillshare.com
forward slash Deep dive and then once
your trial is over you can choose to
carry on with the subscription I pay for
skillshare I think it's great they've
got loads of classes and so it becomes
one of my first places to go to if I
want to teach myself anything at all so
check out my classes on skillshare and
thank you so much skillshare for
sponsoring this episode one thing that I
I've had in my mind a little bit is
because I've heard a bunch of podcasts
and things as well that you know you
should try and wake up at the same time
every morning and preferably on weekends
as well because Rhythm and stuff yeah
but I'll occasionally have a night where
I've had friends over until like 1am and
then I'm like okay so I normally wake up
at 7 30. if I sleep at 1 30 and like
maybe I'll get six hours of sleep is it
better for me to just actually wake up
at 7 30 or should I just have a bit of a
line wake up at 9 30. I think it's fine
to have the occasional lion okay and I
think this is it I it's these regimental
sergeant majors you know it's it's
flexible I mean I think we could think
of we don't do the same behavior when
we're awake and I think during sleep
it's again a dynamic uh it's a dynamic
behavior and this flexibility clearly
there's a baseline you know that we need
to achieve but you know it it's a
wobbling bass line yeah because I think
like over the last couple of weeks I
have actually been sort of putting in my
journal but like huh I feel particularly
tired today oh I only I only did get
like five and a half hours of sleep last
night because uh regimental Sergeant
told me I should wake up at 7 30 even if
I'm tired
um and of course you know catch up sleep
can work you've just got to be very
careful about it uh because uh it can
mean that you don't get that Morning
Light which is so important to set the
clock yeah and if you sleep through so
yeah it will cause a wobble uh but if
you if if the next day you're getting up
at the right time then it's it's fine
um when you so when you say morning
lights um are we talking like what sort
of time are we talking what sort of
looks like what's what's going on there
it's it's outside light is is what we
really need uh and I think
it's because the visual system is so
good at uh adapting to different light
levels uh we're not really aware of the
fact that we live in dim dark caves most
uh sitting rooms uh offices you'll be
lucky to get three 400 Lux of light
intensity whereas right by a window
you'll get on average 3000 Lux
uh shading environment will be maybe 10
000 Lux 20 000 Lux bright sunny day 80
to 100 000. that's a huge difference
between even just being indoors
absolutely and so that's why Morning
Light uh outdoor light is so good
maybe the explanation for example why
individuals with dogs
um are reported to sleep better because
of course they have to get up take them
for a walk in the morning and they're
getting their their morning Photon
shower
um and that's helping consolidate the
sleep wake rhythms of not only
themselves of course but the dog and are
we talking like five a.m morning or like
10 a.m we're talking I suppose you know
seven eight o'clock in the morning I
mean certainly the earlier you get up uh
if you got up at 5am you would have a
big advancing effect upon the clock but
most of the time we're talking about a
mild modulation just nudging it to keep
on track because uh on average and again
I don't like to use averages but but the
Harvard group have suggested that the
human body clock is around about 24
hours and 12 minutes and 10 minutes so
we only need a slight adjustment uh
every day so it's not a huge adjustment
unlike of course when we cross multiple
time zones and then we've got one heck
of a shift because you know we're eight
hours or six hours or going to Australia
you know Tour New Zealand 12 hours of
time difference and of course it takes
about a day for every time zone we've
crossed to adjust you know fully adjust
so it's a it's a it's a and again it
goes back to that wonderful molecule
sick one which is buffering the effects
of light on the clock because of course
it makes sense it doesn't want
evolutionarily huge shifting of the
clock it doesn't want it to be disturbed
because for example you might then if
you're a a borrowing mammal emerge from
your your burrow to late or too early
and be somebody else's lunch yeah so it
sounds it sounds like broadly even
though we don't like to give
prescriptions to people but going for a
walk in the morning feels like a very
reasonable yes good thing to do and
having your breakfast right by a window
so in the nursing home environment where
it's many individuals don't get out very
much and where sleep wake is really
awful in some cases and indeed the light
environment umran a wonderful colleague
from the Netherlands you know put in the
nursing home environment big Banks of
likes of producing a thousand to two
thousand Lux
um darkness in the bedrooms and can
Consolidated really ragged sleep weight
profiles into much more robust sleep
weight profiles and what was interesting
is that those individuals who showed a
stable sleepwear profile uh their
cognition went up by almost 10 percent
so there's a very nice correlation there
with improved sleep and cognition in the
elderly simply by regulating the
Circadian system one thing I noticed
starkly like two days ago I I happened
to be in a co-working space on Baker
Street and it was quite dark and dim
inside I was there for a few hours
working on my book and after like I was
doing this I was thinking huh why do I
feel kind of kind of sad this is a bit
weird and then I went out and then I sat
in a cafe on Baker Street and I was
immediately just like oh my God life is
gray I feel so good and I was thinking
have I had enough coffee I have another
I was like wait a minute it must be like
natural light yes where this was quite a
dingy co-working space it was quite dark
very sort of yellow light and stuff it
just felt a bit like there was a well
yeah that's a really important
observation so so those photosensitive
retinal ganglion cells we talked and we
originally thought of them as circadian
light Regulators then we discovered
they're actually part of the pupil
constriction is is being is dependent
upon those extraordinary new cells and
now we know that levels of alertness and
mood can be regulated so there's an
acute effect of light uh detected by
those cells on on our behavior and and
in fact there's some really fascinating
data showing wonderful study compared uh
light treatment which was 30 minutes of
10 000 Lux from a light box okay first
thing in the morning versus Prozac
versus placebo and by eight weeks
Prozac was statistically different from
Placebo
by two weeks light was statistically
different from Placebo and by eight
weeks light was much more effective than
Prozac interestingly they combined
Prozac and light and the two were
additive suggesting that they may be
operating on our levels of alertness and
mood via different regulatory systems so
we do we don't know what that what light
is actually doing whether it's a direct
acute effect you know increasing
alertness and engagement in the brain or
something else uh so yeah they're
turning out I think that's what's so
really remarkable because it's not just
the regulation of the clock these new
receptors they're having a whole role in
in a sense an unconscious effect of
light on our biology which as you point
out you know is important on our mood
for example yeah
um so there's a lot of people that get
kind of seasonal seasonal affective
disorder is that basically a light
intent density thing from it seems to be
I mean I think many of us were very
skeptical when this was you know
seasonal affective disorder was was was
first talked about because what's the
control you know you can't see something
in front of a light box you know without
the lights on because they kind of get
it
um and then the studies became much more
effective and compared Morning Light
versus evening light and we've talked
about the importance of Morning Light
Morning Light was much more effective at
regulating sad than evening light and
very specifically blue light which is
where those photosensitive rectal
ganglion cells are maximally sensitive
and was more effective than other
wavelengths other colors in reducing the
effects of of sat
um and and so I think it's a real
phenomenon friends who are psychiatrists
don't think it is they think that's just
another form of you know um of of
anxiety or or or depression
um but but I think the data are now
sufficiently strong to show that there's
a there's a genuine light effect
um precisely what the mechanism is we
don't know
um what we do know is it's not melatonin
and so we're talking about myths earlier
yeah so so melatonin is often called a
sleep hormone it is emphatically not a
sleep hormone okay what is it it's a
biological marker of the dark okay which
means so if we if we again if if we can
go back to my roots
um and the comparative what we know
about melatonin in mammals is that the
expanding Seasons so the increasing dark
length in the autumn and winter leads to
an increasing uh release of melatonin so
melatonin Maps the seasonal changes in
light and dark and what uh a sheep or a
deer or something will do is use that
increasing melatonin profile in the
Autumn to trigger reproduction so that
there's the breeding and there's
um the young are gestating over the
winter and they're born in the March
when there's lots of lots of fresh
vegetation to sustain milk production
and weaning
um so that's that's the really
exquisitely understood understood role
of melatonin melatonin if you look at
individuals who are on beta blockers and
you you reduce their levels of melatonin
by over 80 sent then sleep is not is not
really affected if you look at
quadriplegics why beta blockers uh
because it blocks the sympathetic
regulation of the pineal gland which
then regulates the output of the
Melatonin okay so it's easy it's quite
interesting that the people on beta
blockers um do show um almost no
melatonin release but but the
interesting studies and again you have
to read the papers so there's a study
showing quadriplegic individuals those
people who tragically you know severed
their spinal cord you know at the level
of the neck have nothing you know below
the neck
um have terrible sleep
um and that's the argument was
originally well that's because they're
not producing any pineal melatonin then
you compare those individuals to
paraplegics who of course can regulate
their pineal melatonin production they
also have terrible sleep and it's not
different from the quadriplegics so it's
it's the the the ghastliness of losing
some you know of not being mobile that's
the problem with this sleep not the lack
of melatonin and in the best studies
ever undertaken taking melatonin before
you go to bed can reduce the time it
takes to get to sleep by 30 minutes and
I stress that's the best study ever
undertaken many studies showed no
effects whatsoever so let's study do you
mean the most the most the most positive
study exactly the most best conducted
stuff exactly yeah the one the one that
showed the most the greatest efficacy
might be that yeah so it can be thought
of as a mild modular you know you you
also see people right oh well um light
in the middle of the night
um uh increases alertness because it's
suppressing melatonin
um well it does suppress melatonin but
the alerting effect occurs before
there's any decrease in melatonin so it
it's an acute effect upon the brain not
via melatonin so there's a there's a
whole whole mass of of again nonsense
out there about melatonin just on the
Melatonin note because I have I I know a
bunch of people who are super into the
whole optimizing human body type stuff
yeah who will sort of think are dabbling
with like micro dosing melatonin or like
taking melatonin when you're jet lagged
what what does the research say on um
for melatonin for jet lag in some
individuals it can it can speed up a
little bit to the rate at which you lock
on to the new uh the new um time zone so
Josephine Lawrence showed that those
those findings a few years ago but it's
a mild effect uh don't worry about
taking melatonin I think not and in fact
Pilots are warned not to uh because it
might have a slight sleep inductive
effect and even worse um if it does
affect the clock you don't know where
the clock is with multiple you know
changes of time zones I I tried it a lot
when I was flying to Australia and I
found that in fact it it actually didn't
help me at all and in fact it was quite
weird because you're not recommended to
take melatonin if you are uh vulnerable
to depression or mental illness because
it's quite similar to things like
serotonin now I'm not luckily vulnerable
to depression but but weirdly uh after
taking melatonin and this is an N of one
so you know it counts for nothing but I
I found I I was not as robustly Jolly as
I as I normally am uh so I I stopped
using it and of course the thing to do
in the new time zone if you're traveling
west seek out light so you know London
to New York get out in the afternoon in
New York and and that will help you
adjust when traveling uh East for more
than three four time zones then avoid
Morning Light uh and seek out afternoon
light and that's because if you're still
based on London time you see light in
the new time zone when you're traveling
East that would delay the clock shove
you back towards Europe here rather than
Advance the clock
um and drag you forward to India or
Australia we said Morning Light advances
the clock yes and evening like delays
the clock that's right but afternoon
afternoon light of course when you're in
Australia would be dusk in the UK which
would delay the clock which is what you
up oh okay so it's not the nature of the
light it's the timing of the timing of
the light yeah okay so what you need to
do is you need to get
um when you're in Australia you need to
get light
to advance the clock
and so because you're dragging it
forward in time and when you say Advance
the clock that means you're going to
sleep later it would no no Advanced
account means you you go to bed earlier
and get up earlier which is what's
what's happening in Australia okay
whereas of course if you get it at the
wrong time you could you could delay the
clock and and take you back to Europe
I know it's complicated
um and you have to think about it yeah
but the key thing is uh work out when
Dawn and dusk is in London let's say and
knowing that dusk delays the clock and
thus delays DND morning advances work
out what it would be in Australia and
then then uh exposure like MADD morning
advances dust delays and by advancing
the body clock that means we drag you
forward to Australia in time it'll make
you get up earlier because remember
they're getting up earlier but they're
getting up you know 12 hours earlier
than we are yeah
um and of course you know if you're
going west to the States they're getting
up behind us
so you want to delay going west and
Advance going east it's difficult to
hold in one's mind yeah but but it'll
click yeah oh God yeah that makes sense
yeah so so how do you avoid Morning
Light um when you first arrive in
Australia
um dark glasses yeah oh sunglasses
sunglasses okay how much does that tend
to reduce your Lux that will reduce it
very significantly okay yeah I mean it's
not perfect but I I mean you know you're
in Australia so you're not going to hang
out in the in the in the hotel yeah I'll
be foolish okay I heard something around
you should watch the sunset in the
evening because that will like do
something to your circadian rhythm
what's what's going on there well again
it's all part of that that dawn dusk
exposure
um and and it's uh it's getting that
symmetrical exposure which is nudging
the clock backwards and forwards and
keeping it on cue and and of course when
we're all agricultural workers that's
what we got you know we're out of out at
dawn and bed at dusk and that's why we
were so beautifully aligned and you know
that's what we've spent most of our
evolutionary history but
industrialization essentially has cut us
off from natural light exposure yeah
because I guess like in the in the
winter there's not that many hours of
daylight if you were to get Morning
Light and evening light in the winter
time would we end up sleeping for longer
well or so what we know is that the
extreme situation in Scandinavia if you
go to Tromso where you don't get light
for two months of the year and there's
constant light of course is that
um many families in Tromso they actually
have a Lightroom
um so they all the whole family bundles
into this room with with
um you know light boxes to get their
morning light exposure to set the clock
um it's also fascinating uh what um
Arctic reindeer do
um so so during the two months of
darkness they turn off their circadian
clocks so they're not showing any
24-hour patterns at all first of all
there's no light dark cycle so there's
you know kind of no point but also
enjoying the winter uh the the drive is
to feed as much as you possibly can
whenever the weather conditions permit
and of course in summer where there's
constant light again there's no
circadian change uh but the key thing
during summer is you feed all the time
because you've got to pack on enough
calories to last the winter so that's a
great example of where a clock actually
isn't of any adaptive value So In Those
Animals As arctic animals you turn it
off now in humans we've only been in
those environments for a few thousand
years except for the native peoples in
in Northern in the Arctic Circle we
don't quite know what's going on with
those individuals
um but certainly uh in those arctic
animals you have an Adaptive response
where they turn their clocks off
so in terms of sort of actionable things
broadly sleeping or sleeping and waking
up at the same time each day with a bit
of leeway because it's a wobbly
waistline rather than a regimented thing
uh going for a walk in the morning is
the first thing could you know very
reasonable thing to do um getting some
level of like natural light exposure in
the evening as well yeah I mean I think
that's right as long as it's symmetrical
that's great I will end spy symmetrical
you mean I mean I mean so that you're
getting Dawn and dusk you're not just
getting dusk which is what you know
which would just delay the clock like as
those University students yeah okay that
makes a lot of sense what's the deal
with
um you should turn off you should dim
the lights and stuff in the evening and
you should put on candles in the evening
and she won't do light blockers in the
evening what's going on there so this is
another another
um issue I have and and so if you read
the Press
uh then looking at a Kindle before you
go to bed uh is an absolute disaster
because it'll it'll change your sleep
wake timing
um there are data that looked at this so
the Harvard group got people to look at
a Kindle on on its brightest intensity
for four hours just before bedtime on
five consecutive nights and it just
statistically delayed sleep onset by 10
minutes oh perfect because I read Kindle
before bed
orange light setting but one of my
colleagues said well it may be
statistically significant but it's
biologically meaningless right so going
back to the you know our Point earlier
which is you need a lot of light for a
long duration to actually affect the
clock
um and so these devices the the Kindles
are producing 30 Lux
um now you can get an effect on the
clock with
200 Lux or so
but you need six and a half hours of
exposure right so so again it's
titrating intensity and duration yeah so
there will be a slight wobble
um but it's going to be very mild and of
course if you're getting morning natural
light it's going to correct any evening
wobble
um so for most devices the light is not
the issue it's the alerting effect and
where we have really nice data are for
smartphones for example which have this
incredible alerting effect not least in
teenagers and that will uh increase
levels of alertness and therefore delay
sleep onto it lovely lovely anecdote I
mean I remember speaking to
um a young lad and I said um uh not
smart you know to look at your your
smartphone
um before you go to bed he said look
look you know it's okay with my computer
I have my smartphone I've got a device
uh which changes the color from Blue to
to Red so it's just not a problem for me
okay and I said okay well there's not
really much evidence that there has much
of an effect at all
um and by the way what time are you
getting to sleep you said well about 2
30 in the morning yeah and so you can
actually fool yourself that you're
protecting yourself with a with a screen
that changes its color yeah and actually
it's not having an effect at all other
than you know it's on on the clock it's
essentially this alerting effect that it
does and many young people are aware
that this is not a smart idea but the
anxiety of being disconnected from
social media and the friend circle is
overwhelming and and so so it's it's you
know our advice is always look you know
try and be disciplined about it and I
know how difficult it is we talked about
Australia I those of you who remember
black priests I I just got my Blackberry
and you may remember we used to have one
of those red lights that used to sort of
glow when there was a message so I had
my Australian emails
um that was fine and then the European
ones would come in
um which of course would be bedtime and
then the American ones will come in
which of course will be even later and
so I I know I'm weak like everybody else
I had to leave my Blackberry uh in the
lab because I would um uh I would you
know because because I had jet lag I was
a sleeping great you know and I'd sort
of wake up and I'd see this glowing red
light and I and and so I think you if it
is a problem you had to do something
about it which is detach yourself from
it
um yeah I found like the one of the
biggest sort of tweaks I made to my
sleep was just moving my phone charger
across the room rather than on my
bedside table so now the only thing I
have on my bedside is a Kindle and a fan
I think there's a strong argument for
all of us not to use our phones as alarm
clocks and go back to an old you know
either digital
um or you know mechanical you have to be
slightly careful because some people
clock watch which means you wake up as
we've discussed and um and and of course
normally most of us would fall back to
sleep it's not a big deal but then you
see the glowing dial on your on your
bedside table uh I think oh my god I've
only got two hours before the alarm goes
off
um and it then sends you into a state of
anxiety which means you won't go back to
sleep so for those individuals just
cover up the the digital numbers because
it's actually the important thing is
when the alarm goes off not how long it
is before the alarm guys off yeah I
remember so this morning so I I have my
alarm set for half seven but I woke up
at like 6 50. and I was thinking Hmm I
feel pretty alert right now but I know
I'm gonna talk to you
like I wonder if I should just and I
went back to sleep and woke up that's it
I was thinking about it for like 30
seconds it's a great example whereby one
one just can chill and you can go back
and you can get that you you know it's
it's it's the terror of waking up again
it's part of that sort of we're so
frightened of the seat we're not getting
that we then don't get it it's such a
shame so is it better for you to wake up
without needing an alarm or are alarms
totally reasonable if you're waking up
naturally without an alarm it's telling
you you probably had a good night's
sleep
you also May wake up remembering your
dream because of course we go through a
series of stages which is the sort of
the non-rem
REM cycle REM standing for rapid eye
movement sleep which is when the when
you're essentially paralyzed from the
neck down and your and your eyes if
you've got a sleeping partner it's just
it's sometimes fascinating to see you
know the eyes wobbling behind the
um the the eyelids if you don't have a
sleeping partner then well you can sit
in your dog or whatever
um and it's just such an incredible
state but it's during REM sleep that we
have our most Vivid uh uh dreams and we
wait naturally from REM sleep so those
individuals who are waking up in the
morning naturally are much more likely
to remember their their dreams and while
we're talking about dreams um I think
it's really important to stress uh
there's nothing to worry about with
dreams dreams are a way of
um the brain probably trying to make
sense of uh our emotions and uh
struggling with what we may or may not
have experienced uh you know during the
previous few days they do not anticipate
things I mean mean it's there's no
evidence for that whatsoever but they do
seem to be associated with our emotional
status so for example after the Twin
Towers were destroyed
uh there are lots of dreams not of
seeing planes crash into the buildings
which is interesting because that was
the image that was constantly on the
television but people had anxiety dreams
of being mugged being overwhelmed by a
tsunami so so so yes our dreams do
reflect our emotional status but you
shouldn't be worried about them because
it's the brain trying to work through
these issues
um just on the point of the whole uh
blue light yellow light thing yeah
you know every device these days seems
to have a nighttime setting where
they'll suddenly go orange and yes I
guess that lulls us into a full sense of
security oh it's not too bad using my
computer at like midnight because it's
it's orange I think that's the thing yes
um there's very little evidence that
that shift in wavelength color will have
any effect upon the clock
um color is only important
um when under certain circumstances
um if if the light is bright it doesn't
really matter what the color is
um and we can talk about blue glasses in
a moment uh so yeah I think it does
listen to a false sense of security and
you just need to stop using uh these
these devices uh it it could well have a
mild effect because after all these
cells are maximally sensitive to the
blue part of the spectrum but you're so
low that it probably just doesn't matter
much as more about the alerting it's
yeah exactly it's it's the alerting
effect
um of of the content that you're
processing and uh and it may well be
some contribution of the alerting effect
of light it looks as though the the
threshold for regulation of the clock is
higher you need more light to regulate
the clock than you would to have an
alerting effect ironically what's the
last thing that most of us do which is
stand in the most brightly lit room in
the house the bathroom you're looking
into an illuminated mirror while we
clean our teeth and I've I've often
thought there's a commercial opportunity
to have a bathroom mirror with a bright
Morning Light setting to increase
alertness as before we leave the leave
the house and slightly dim it to reduce
alertness before
um before we go to bed yeah yes and in
the place I'm in at the moment there's a
dimmer switch in the bathroom that's so
good like as soon as it's night time I'm
just like them all the way down and then
let's feel like yeah
um so presumably a light like this on
full blast would probably not be
advisable but even then I guess
yeah yeah I mean I think I think that
said it's it's it's it's not gonna have
too much effect on the clock but but it
but it will have levels of alertness and
and we go back to you know one of the
questions you asked earlier which is you
know how much light what's the color
um uh how long and for humans we just
don't really have those data to design
proper human-centric lighting for our
indoor spaces it's a huge um area of
interest at the moment
um so uh yeah it's It's Tricky we need
more research and you know and it's not
as though we couldn't do it we can
measure the spectral composition from
small devices we can measure the
intensity and what I'd love to do is is
get a whole bunch of people
um and measure their light exposure
wavelength intensity throughout the day
their levels of alertness with a simple
sort of a response on a smartphone uh
their sleep wake timing you could
collect all this data cross correlate
and then actually get some good Baseline
data for human-centric lighting worth
bearing in mind of course that the most
important light is at dawn and dusk so
what we do in the middle of the day may
not matter that much that's the
prediction but we don't have the data so
we were talking a little bit about yeah
about like the blue light stuff
presumably then blue like glasses are a
bit of a myth yes and in fact uh if you
think about what blue light glasses do
they will transmit blue and block out
all the other wavelengths but
um transmit blue so a filter works
because it transmits one particular
wavelength okay it passes through the
glass yeah and blocks others right so
it's not increasing the amount of blue
light it's exactly the same it's just
you know filtering blue light so if
people use blue glasses to enhance their
alertness right then yeah exactly
there's no more blue light it's just
blue light blocking glasses blocking
glasses because they're just getting rid
of the blue they're just getting rid of
the blue and do blue blocking uh lenses
work well they probably have some effect
upon alertness
um they may have some effect on Shifting
the clock but it's going to be very mild
if the light is bright enough it doesn't
matter what the color is so if you're
outside you're going to be exposed to so
much light
um you know in the thousands hundreds to
thousands of Lux range that will shift
the clock and in fact there was a
consensus statement just produced
recently from I think australasian uh
ophthalmologists which suggested that
blue blocking and uh and blue enhancing
glasses had no effect at all and they
were not they were not recommended I
mean we did some work on
um cataract surgery so
um if you have a cataract and
incidentally there's an interesting
observation here which you might find
amusing why is it that perfectly
respectable elderly ladies have a blue
rinse
they have their hair dyed blue oh do
they they're in the in the olden days
um and it's and still to some extent and
that's because they don't want their
hair to look yellow so what happens as
you age is your lens
yellows so white hair looks looks yellow
white teeth with the ghetto yeah yes and
and so therefore blue will make the
their hair look white so that's an old
historical reference but anyway so so we
asked the question
uh does do blue blocking versus UV
blocking lenses make any difference to
sleep wake regulation uh after cataract
cataract surgery and now we've done
calculations showing that most
commercially available blue blocking
lenses actually
um transmit uh more blue light than a
normal healthy lens so it's not going to
scrub the Circadian system and that's
exactly what we found we found no
difference between UV blocking and blue
blocking on seat rate timing in after
cataract surgery people still use blue
blocking in the clinic because there's
some not great data suggesting that blue
light might enhance age-related macular
degeneration
now this the evidence for that in a dish
in vitro is reasonably good but in Vivo
in humans
the data are not good at all but I think
that people are on the side of caution
and will use a blue blocking uh lens uh
under most circumstances so when I was
getting these glasses from the eye
people they were like well you could pay
an extra 100 pounds and you can get blue
light thing on them I was like
why and they were like well if you work
with a screen a lot it might be good for
you I was like okay I mean I work with
the screen a lot and now I have this
sort of slightly yellow Hue in my
glasses which I now kind of want to get
rid of because it's actually just makes
the World Slightly unpleasant yeah um
why would you do it well quite but the
optician chat up sold me on this 100
pound upgrade because apparently it's
better quick better for you if you use a
screen do you know what he's getting out
there or is it yeah yeah it's part of
this whole myth again right this is this
is that you know blue blocking um I yell
slightly yellow tinted is good
um uh if you're looking at the screen
but why
um I mean you know you're gonna get much
more Blue Light by walking outside
um and I don't think we have any real
evidence base for a lot of the stuff
that's been being
um pedaled at the moment now I'm very
happy to change my mind and admit that
you know with new data it may it may be
important but we don't at the moment
have the data
um and it would be very valuable I think
yeah for you when you go back to your
optician to say oh point me to the paper
yeah where this has been shown to be
effective and I think everybody should
be doing that I think I think we should
be challenging you know all of this by
saying oh I'm very happy to do it but
you know just show me the paper and
where it's statistically significant
maybe I'm just becoming a bit grumpy as
I get older all right time to get rid of
these blue
um one thing I've heard is that it is
good for you if in the evening you like
candles because like the low sort of
getting light from a low area like a
candle or a lamp the photosensitive
retinal ganglion cells respond
differently to light from above so turn
off the ceiling lights and turn on the
lamp lights
um again I don't know what the evidence
base for that is but of course light in
addition to its alerting effect
um and of course it's regulation of the
clock will impinge Upon Our emotions but
but depending on context you know
um romantic candles uh and it could well
be an association that we make with
these different light sources rather
than any direct
physiological response I wouldn't say I
suppose you could call it perhaps a
placebo effect it's it's it's it's a a
perceived impact but actually it may
just be you know in the cortex rather
than any yeah
yeah it's like oh I'm just you know I'm
lighting my candles with my wind down
routine and actually you know we're
joking but but actually developing a
wind down routine at the end of the day
is really important before you go to bed
and if it's you know candles that that
do it and and even sort of for some form
of smell whether it be you know lavender
or something else the evidence that that
sort of um oils actually do have an
effect above Placebo is not very good in
fact it's negligible uh but if it works
then I think that's that's fine it's
it's like it's like any relaxation
techniques I mean I have to say in the
early days when people were sort of
getting peddling um
mindfulness I sort of put it in the box
of Crystal waving um and that's you know
kind of my grumpy sort of background as
I you know really I want mechanisms I
want physiology I want to understand how
it actually works and then actually I
got in I sort of studied it a bit and I
realized essentially what mindfulness is
is a brilliant way of finding relaxation
techniques and relaxation techniques
work
um we don't understand necessarily the
mechanisms but they do work and so at
the end of the the day
trying to get rid of the stresses
um then I think relaxation techniques
whatever they are can be extremely
useful I mean in our house
I banned the discussion of family
finances you know and and it's a shame
because it's often the only time of the
day that you couples do have chance to
talk about come sort of serious issues
because you get up you rush off to work
you know you then get your dinner and
then you have that sort of period of
relaxation but actually what you don't
want to fill that time with is angst
promoting discussions
um and so I think trying to find a time
um maybe at the weekend where you can
have those discussions is so important
but not immediately before you go to bed
my wife still tries though oh yeah
family finances
um what's uh so you talk in in the book
a little bit about stress and the
effects of stress on yeah how does
stress and body circadian rhythms and
sleep and stuff interact I think this is
such an important Point
um most people don't have a sleep
problem they have a sleep or anxiety
problem and so you know the the the the
worry that they have is preventing them
getting this sleep that they they need
um and I think while we're talking about
it it's worth
distinguishing between sleepiness and
fatigue
sleepiness is cured by the opportunity
to sleep
fatigue is you can be sleeping a lot
longer but you're still feeling tired
exhausted lacking energy during the day
and so many people with covid for
example had fatigue they had long
periods of sleep but they were still
feeling exhausted and Below par and what
fatigue represents is an underlying
health issue
um which is different from sleepiness so
if you you get persistent fatigue then
there's a chance you have some
underlying health issue which you need
to get explored I I was chatting to to
somebody in the states just recently and
she was telling me that
um she was feeling tired all the day she
couldn't couldn't work
um and then she'd go to bed and then
she'd wake up in the night
um and of course ideally you'd fall back
to sleep but she was so uh alarmed at
all the stuff she'd failed to do during
the day she couldn't then get back to
sleep and it transpired actually she had
an immune problem which of course was
leading to her fatigue and so so sorting
out the immune issue which was causing
the fatigue which then was causing the
anxiety which is then stopping her sleep
and so I think it's really important to
try and dissect all of these things you
know what's distress do it increases
blood pressure it increases levels of
alertness you know it pumps out the
cortisone an adrenaline it makes us more
alert and so if you are stressed it's
going to be tricky to sleep and so
that's why it's so important to make
that Detachment at the end of the day
from the things that have upset you you
know mindfulness anything yoga whatever
um and of course the problem during
covid and since is that many people's
bedrooms have become their places of
work uh because the bedroom has where
you can set up your office and that's of
course there's they're made for many
people be no other possibility but by
combining your sleeping space with your
workspace it means that your opportunity
to sleep is going to be affected by oh
um maybe I should just just check the
email again you know before I go to
sleep or whatever or if you wake up you
know the Tendencies are just just check
if those those emails came in from this
from the states and it has such an
allergic effect you won't go back to
sleep so if you I do have to have your
office in your bedroom you've got to be
really disciplined turn everything off
and make it a real pain to have to turn
it on if you have to wake in the night
yeah so I guess
um do you know like what the data is
around I mean I've heard that uh acute
stress is kind of good for you but like
chronic stress is like bad for you yeah
I think that that's a really important
point and I have likened stress to a bit
bit like um the gears of a of an engine
so uh acute stress is like first gear it
gives you that wonderful acceleration
you can get away and do your stuff but
if you leave the engine in first gear
chronic stress then you're going to
destroy the engine and that's I think a
very interesting analogy because yes
stress and we give you know
um stress a bad time but actually it's
evolutionarily really important it gives
us that massive acceleration to get out
of problems if the fight will flight
response but it's where we have to keep
on turning that mechanism on to function
and that's what tired people do a night
shift worker their entire biology
um
is in the sleep mode it's really
important to stress that night shift
workers 97 of night shift workers do not
adapt to the demands of working at night
so they're working against an entire
biology which is saying you should be
asleep
and the override for that of course is
turning on the stress axis which of
course has which explains why long-term
night shift work is associated with such
chronic health conditions coronary heart
disease type 2 diabetes you know what
are you doing when you when you turn the
stress axis on you're throwing glucose
into the circulation to try and burn it
up because you're going to need it for
running away or fighting now if you're
not then it just you become glucose
intolerant um so obesity same thing
um higher rates of cancer in night shift
workers because what happens one thing
we know about high levels of of cortisol
they'll suppress the immune system
making you more vulnerable to not only
infection but cancer so so yeah stress
and sleep um and the need to activate
the stress axis to override the need to
sleep is such an important part of our
24 7 Society this might be a little bit
outside of your field of expertise but I
wonder if you ever thought on this um
around around stress and kind of
taking vacations where you switch off uh
or switch off from work I guess and I
guess I'm asking because in this you
know when I was working as a doctor it
was it was easy enough to switch off
from work because being a complete
Junior I have no responsibility for
anything that happens when I'm not
around so broadly it was good and that's
like oh crap I've ever made a mistake um
I thought the Consultants were a bit
more on edge about this because they're
responsible for patients overnight but
now doing this YouTube podcast writing
type stuff in a way my work is my life
and it's so tightly integrated that when
I take time off I'm still always doing
some work related thing or another and
people will say oh it's really important
to fully switch off and I'd be like well
I don't know like I kind of enjoy it but
I don't know if I'm bullshitting myself
yeah I'm kind of like you
um I don't feel as though I completely
switch off
um I'm going to be taking a holiday
later this week uh but what are my plans
what do I want to do well I I want to
kind of do a bit of reading
um around my subject area uh and I find
that relaxing I wouldn't do that
immediately before going to bed having
this wonderful new book on what I said
read but it'll be during the day so I
think again you do the stuff that
relaxes you
um and and of course it's going to be
some people
um Laguna Beach other people doing
different things other people
uh mixing up a a a a naughty cocktail
yeah I know and and I think you know
it's very much up to the individual
um so Okay so we've talked a little bit
about stress um what's uh how does how
do you how does I guess exercise relate
to our circadian rhythm yeah that's
um interesting first thing is that part
of the Sleep mechanism is a drop in core
body temperature
uh and individuals if if you block that
drop in core body temperature it's more
difficult to get to sleep
um and it's only about a drop in of
about a degree so if you exercise
uh late
fairly shortly before you go to bed
you're going to increase core body
temperature and it might be more
difficult to get off to sleep
um exercise uh depends on why you want
to exercise if you want to burn calories
then there's there's two
two ideas that because night time we're
in a different metabolic status so
during night time
um we are burning stored calories
and we're mobilizing those calories to
keep metabolism going throughout the
sleeping stage during the day we're
taking calories in and we're
metabolizing those calories and and
burning them up ideally
so if you want to exercise before
breakfast first thing in the morning
you're still in the Sleep metabolic
status so you're burning up
um stored calories which for some people
is what they want to do
the trouble is our ability to exercise
increases throughout the day so most
track records swimming records other
athletic performance is peaking in the
late afternoon and early evening so
you'll notice at the people at the
Olympics know this so the finals are
always late afternoon early evening
because that's when individuals can
exercise for longer with greater power
yeah so if you want to
um so if you're a more of an evening
person as I am then I am likely to be
well I will be able to exercise for
longer and exert greater power
um later in the day than first thing in
the morning now if you're a morning
person getting up and doing your
exercise before breakfast that's great
for those of us who would find that
particularly difficult then I think uh
late afternoon and early evening is is
where you go yeah I try I tried so hard
to be uh kind of wake up early in the
morning go to the gym before going to
work kind of guy but I would always find
that it would just be such a chore and I
would look forward to it and be like why
am I doing this is the worst thing ever
and now when I go to the gym at like 5 6
p.m I'm having a great time that's it I
think that's it you find out really what
works best for you and I I and you know
it's it's it's interesting because it
relates to eating
um our our habits our eating habits have
changed profoundly
um with the Industrial Revolution uh
during the 1100s or so the main meal of
the day was breakfast
during the Middle Ages 1100 to 1500 it
shifted to noon and I mean 12 o'clock 11
12 o'clock and that's where the main
meal of the day we think of all those
Tudor Banquets you know with people
throwing chicken legs all over the place
um that was actually lunch time right
not in the evening yeah but with uh the
industrialization and that the workspace
was was different from the living space
and commutes and and all the rest of it
our main meal of the day many of us will
run out the door with breakfast maybe a
tiny breakfast we probably don't have
time for lunch so we may have a sandwich
in front of the computer and then we'll
get home after a long commute shove
something in the microwave
um and then we'll be massively calorie
you know having a massive calorie load
you know late in the day and what's been
shown is that there's a circadian
regulation of our metabolism so the same
it was a wonderful study looking at um
the same meal at 8am versus 8 pm and
those individuals who are the same same
people but when they had the meal at 8
pm circulating levels of glucose were 17
higher than the same meal at 8 AM and of
course leading late in the day high
levels of glucose uh greater risk of
diabetes 2 obesity and all the rest of
it so when you eat is really important
and the data now are very very
persuasive
um so yeah well so my late night Five
Guys is like worse than my mid-afternoon
Five Guys absolutely okay yes yes when
you're young you're burning it off and
if you can you know much right it's when
you when you get to my decrepit age that
um you can't you really shouldn't and so
so we as we as a family have shifted our
our meal times and we try not to eat
late because of the greater risks
does that a sort of uh eating because
some people say that oh you know don't
eat anything four hours before bed or
something like that is that does that
help you go to sleep if you're not
eating at that time or no I mean It's
tricky because some people feel that
they need to go to bed on a full stomach
to sleep better and the and the and the
science behind that I don't I don't know
I don't know quite what's going on there
uh but certainly some people talk about
it
um
ideally you know all the data would now
suggest that try and minimize your
calorie intake uh I think before four
hours or so before you go to bed because
of the the metabolic side effects okay
rather than because of the Sleep side
effects yeah broadly okay awesome
um you know we we talked a bit a little
bit about body temperature
um one of the things that um everyone
started doing after Matthew Walker's
book came out was sleeping at 19 degrees
and turning the AC on to Max and getting
these fancy mattresses that you cool
your bed uh do you know what the data is
on those things anecdotally I found it
helpful to sleep in a very cold room but
yeah yeah and as as do I anecdotally and
and certainly
um
that dropping core body temperature
prior to sleep is is important
uh whether we need to sleep in you know
a cold air-conditioned room I'm not sure
there is evidence it's not huge but
there is some evidence that those
mattresses that take away heat from the
body
do improve sleep we can get you off to
sleep so I think there's something
emerging there and indeed I am working
with a mattress company I'm advising
them because I do think there's
something there and they approach me and
what was interesting about them is that
they wanted to do the studies which will
show this or not they wanted an Evidence
base for saying that yes here's the
evidence and it does make a difference
and so that's why I was interested in in
working with them and Advising them uh
we talked a little bit and uh earlier
about kind of morning person evening
person and the idea of chronotype yes uh
how does one figure out their chronotype
it's not that difficult there are
questionnaires um
there's a there's a question in a
lifetime which is a well-validated
questionnaire and it basically asks you
know your preferences to a whole bunch
of things and uh I think it raises I
think it's interesting if you know your
chronotype because it might help you
explain certain aspects of your behavior
but but certainly I've also wanted to
encourage employers to take chronotype
into account so if you're on the night
shift
it would make an awful lot of sense if
you had a later chronotype versus a
morning chronotype and uh not that you
would remove all the problems of of
night shift work but if you could match
your Workforce
um and uh so for example I've urged
Banks
um to say right you know this is 24 7
business why don't you develop teams
whereby they're the morning types the
middle types and they're called Larks
doves and and owls but there are a whole
bunch of other animals that are being
used as well for these classifications I
like the old you know um Larks in doves
and owls um and then you've got a team
that can span uh the the 24 7 banking
sector that that will make it easier I
mean you know you put the the the the
owls on the on the um American uh when
that when the American banks are at
their Peak and you know the the Larks
will be when the Asian banks are at
their Peak and I think that working
together across chronotypes could be
really valuable yeah because there's a
lot of like moralizing about the whole
wake up at 5am and you are better than
the sort of person that wakes up at 11AM
kind of thing oh God yeah it's just that
whole machismo of you know and of course
those of us that remember the 80s you
know people would bounce and say oh I've
done another all-nighter and you know
people used to slap them on the back and
that's just nonsense I mean would you
want in the workplace people who were
lacking in empathy overly impulsive and
incapable of making
um sensible decisions no I mean you know
that's the consequence of not getting
enough sleep and so uh yeah I think that
I think those days hopefully mercifully
are gone although uh I understand the
banking Community there was a survey
last year uh and some I think Young
Bankers were saying we're going to
resign if you put you know there's huge
working hours you know completely
stressed I think the majority were
getting less than five hours sleep a
night
um which which maybe a fraction wouldn't
you know could could cope on that
generally but most would not and and of
course do you really want the people
looking after our pensions and our
national economies you know overly
impulsive and failing to make uh
and making sensible decisions about the
economy no
um so I would you know in the same way
that the medical profession has to some
extent ignored the impact of night shift
work I think that the financial sector
is another sector that really needs to
start to take it seriously
I was gonna ask about like these little
[ __ ] sheets you've got in front of you
oh yeah because it seems like you
haven't really consulted them but I
wonder what's what's on them so so if
one was gonna structure you know what
what could you do
um to develop sort of an Optimum
sleeping regime perfect
yeah so then I think you can divide you
can divide sort of the day into four
sections I mean so so during the day
um we've talked about light for most of
us 90 of us it will be getting Morning
Light to set the clock
what about napping
um so uh a 20-minute nap in the early
afternoon has been shown to be effective
so the occasional nap you know can can
make you function better during the
second half of the day and some uh
companies you know offer a 20-minute nap
longer than 20 minute nap you you can
drop into a deeper level of sleep and
then recovery from that the Sleep
inertia that you experience can make you
groggy and it can be counterproductive
but a short nap can be effective and are
we talking 20 minutes of actual sleeping
or yeah I mean you you basically um will
will set your timer for 20 minutes you
know and if you're tired you need a nap
you'll probably fall asleep for most of
that there's a big problem though for
teenagers so they for reasons we've
discussed tend to have shortened sleep
so they're they're going to sleep
they're waking up chronically tired and
when you talk to teachers you know there
are kids falling asleep at their desk
they then get home they then will sleep
for two or three hours relatively close
to bedtime that pushes back sleep
pressure which means it's more difficult
to get to sleep that night so you fall
into a cycle of later delayed sleep
um shortened sleep and then extended not
naps but really sleeps during the day so
you need to be careful you don't fall in
into that cycle
um so so napping can be useful
occasionally you know that's fine
exercise again we've touched on not too
close to bedside but bedtime because of
course it can raise quality temperature
but the key thing is to exercise
um concentrating food intake during the
first and middle parts of the day why
well of course if you having your
calorie intake towards the end of the
day you're much more likely to lay it
down it's fat that you are more likely
to have conditions like obstructive
sleep apnea
which can massively harm your sleep at
night so you know that's one thing to be
careful of uh avoid excessive
consumption of caffeine so many of us
will not drink coffee after two or three
o'clock in the afternoon
caffeine has a long Half-Life I mean for
depending on who you are five to nine
hours so you know a late afternoon cup
of coffee can again delay sleep at that
night
um when you leave work
when you stop work you've got to make
time to step back and switch into
another mode some sort of relaxation you
mentioned going to the gym that's that's
great it's doing something that is
completely different from your your your
work so that's sort of things you can
think about during the day before bed
reduce the light again we've touched on
this it's not because it's going to have
a big effect upon the clock light will
have an alerting effect so minimize
light exposure 30 minutes before you go
to bed stop using electronic devices
again same thing you need to be winding
down
I'd ideally avoid prescription sedatives
it's really important to be aware that
sleeping tablets are sedatives they do
not provide a biological mimic for sleep
you know basically they
encourage a neurotransmitter which turns
off all of those alerting
neurotransmitters in the brain and it's
been shown that it can reduce for
example memory consolidation and can
promote daytime sleepiness particularly
in the elderly and sleeping tablets are
really not recommended for things like
dementia and stuff like that
alcohol many people will have a have a
have a sort of a cycle of excessive
coffee during the day to keep myself
awake and then sedate themselves without
alcohol at night really bad idea alcohol
is a again a sedative it can disrupt the
natural pattern of REM non-rem sleep and
it can again harm memory consolidation
and the processing of of information
again we've touched on this before you
go to bed avoid discussing topics that
have a stressful alerting effect upon
you and then finally you know before bed
it's wind down and whether it's reading
that Kindle which works for you
um whether it's listening to a piece of
classical music whether it's listening
to Radio 4 extra whatever it is you know
what works for you so that's sort of
during the day and before bed the
bedroom itself
it shouldn't be too warm again we've
talked about this loss in core body
temperature if the bedroom is too warm
it's much more difficult to get off to
sleep
again ideally it should be quiet now
that's tricky of course in many sort of
apartments and flats people have used
white noise or relaxing sounds such as
whale song or the sea and again try it
out it it may work dark if possible and
particularly if you're getting a lot of
Street lighting through you can get
blackout curtains that can go behind
your normal curtains
as much as you possibly can remove TV
computers all of those sorts of alerting
effects from the bedroom space as as
we've discussed really tricky because
many bedrooms have become also offices
so make it difficult to turn those
devices on
um don't clock watch again we've touched
on this uh the illuminated dial on your
clock can be used if you wake up and oh
my god I've only got a few hours people
have to get up doesn't matter so so
cover it up and of course don't use your
smartphone so maybe just go back to an
old mechanical clock although I'm told
that the tick tock now for some people
drives them completely crazy
um
sleep apps
don't take sleep app seriously again as
we've discussed none of them are
endorsed by the national sleep
federations they can be deeply
misleading and can actually make you
more anxious about your sleep what
they're useful for
is telling you roughly when you went to
sleep how many times you work in the
night and when you work up that can be
useful because if you want to change
your sleep timing or your sleep duration
then you can modify your behaviors and
then have a accurate record of that with
your app so in the same way if you want
to lose weight you can change your
eating Behavior you weigh yourself in
the morning you see a change in weight
and that reinforces your your change to
eating Behavior but don't start getting
obsessed about oh I had a good good
night's sleep or I had lots of slow wave
sleep they're just not accurate enough
at the moment to give you that
information then of course in bed again
try to keep to a routine go to bed and
get up at the same times
ensure that the bed is comfortable and
large enough I do feel that
uh webritz are kind of cheap about our
bedding um you know it's a third of our
lives and yet we're very reluctant to
spend on you know decent mattresses and
pillows and of course it depends on who
you are go try them out talk to friends
family about that sort of thing but I do
think it's important to to take it
seriously and invest in good bedding
keep bed sides lights low again you can
read comfortably but you don't have to
have them too bright so it'll have an
alerting effect
now some people sort of Define the
sleeping space with relaxing oils such
as lavender and that can be useful the
evidence that it actually works is not
great but what also people might do is
if they're traveling a lot
they may take
um their partner's aftershave or or
perfume and then Define the sleeping
space uh you know for them in a foreign
place which can can Aid sleep so that's
that's that's funny earplugs now this is
a really interesting area if your
partner snores then earplugs is is one
solution
many people can't cope with earplugs and
so I recommend if you can finding an
alternative sleeping space now that idea
for many particularly
um sort of older couples is is the the
the the sort of the signature of death
for the relationship it absolutely isn't
whether you sleep in the same bed or not
it does not define the quality of your
relationship and I would argue in fact
if you're getting a better night's sleep
in a room next door you'll be more
empathetic you'll have more fun together
um and and you'll be a better person
you're a better person so so don't worry
if you if you feel you need to sleep
elsewhere that as I say doesn't Define
your relationship what you do need to be
very careful about is that your partner
it doesn't have obstructive sleep apnea
and that's where there's a cessation a
stopping of breathing for a period of
time and then they'll wake up with a
gasp and so now that's really serious
and basically what obstructive sleep
apnea is is a collapse of the
musculature of the throat which actually
blocks the the breathe the breathing
channels
um which means you're depriving the
brain of oxygen it detects it's not
getting the oxygen it leaves needs and
it so we'll then wake you up uh now but
that great surge in blood pressure
without waking up has been associated
with uh damage to the small vasculature
within the eye and the brain and of
course those individuals of the
structure of sleep apnea have higher
rates of coronary heart disease and all
the rest of it uh exactly causing
correlation is unclear but you do need
to get it looked at it's it's a serious
issue
um it's been estimated that a very large
number of those individuals running up
are driving our buses and trains have
abstracted sleep apnea causing of course
daytime sleepiness and all of the other
health areas so so get that looked at
and it can I mean CPAP which is this
sort of forced air mask can take a
little of time to get get used to but it
works in over 90 percent of cases so
it's it's fixable
um and finally as we have discussed if
you wake stay calm
um it's not necessarily the end of sleep
you just need to maybe if you're not
falling back to sleep immediately go to
another space and relax and then return
to turn to the bed when you feel when
you feel um able to sleep again and the
key thing is there's lots of things that
you can try sleep so many people think
is sleep is what you get and we and it's
not we can have a lot of control over
our sleep if we're not anxious about it
and as soon as you've found something
that works for you stick to it defend
your sleep
love it firstly thank you so much this
has been wonderful um I guess one thing
I'd like to sort of uh end with is you
know you're
you've had a pretty illustrious career
you're a professor now you teach all
these students uh we have a lot of
students and young people listening or
watching to this uh to this podcast I
guess
what would be your top tips for if you
were if you were able to have a platform
to advise young people about anything or
other for I guess succeeding in life
staying happy healthy
yeah I think it's very it's really
important
um that we get education about the
importance of sleep and circadian
rhythms embedded uh within our schools
uh and and just making the point that uh
if you don't get enough sleep then
you're going to have a negative view of
the world there's some really amazing
studies showing that tired people
um remember uh the negative experiences
but forget the positive ones so you know
it's difficult enough being young but as
it is but but only remembering the
ghastly stuff that's going on rather
than the good stuff means your world
view is completely changed knowing that
not having enough sleep you know you're
going to be more irritable you're going
to be more anxious
um that you'll have loss of empathy
you'll show greater levels of
frustration you'll show increased
tendency to use stimulants and then
sedatives you'll have decreased
cognitive performance moments you know
this is the time of one's life when
you're packing in you know your
educational opportunities and not
embracing one's education because of
lack of sleep is a terrible squandering
of resources
um you'd have poor memory and
concentration without good sleep uh
you'll have impaired decision-making
capacity
um and creativity so all the sorts of
things that make us this extraordinary
species you know humor the ability to to
absorb and use information all of this
is in it is is inhibited by sleep and
you'll also show reduced social
connectivity so so sleep is not an
Indulgence it's not a luxury it's
something that is 30 of our biology or
more and needs to be embraced and it
makes you a happier healthier Lovelier
person and it means what you can do is I
suppose embrace all of the opportunities
that the world has to offer and not
getting enough sleep sleep is kind of a
terrible squandering of of opportunity
fantastic Professor Foster thank you so
much this has been wonderful where can
people learn more about you if they
would want to want to follow up more of
your work oh well there's there's
lifetime of course which I've just
finished so uh um you know much of what
we've discussed is is in lifetime uh and
then you can track me down on our
website to sleep and circadian
Neuroscience Institute at the University
of Oxford brilliant thank you so much
great pleasure thank you all right so
that's it for this week's episode of
Deep dive thank you so much for watching
or listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye